okay fine I'll you know what I'll do it
i-i'll be the Democratic nominee I will
I'll take the job nobody else seems to
want the job so you know you twisted my
arm enough and I will I'll do it I'm in
I take it now I know that I don't
necessarily check all the the boxes
ideologically that that you need to to
be a considerate of Liberal Democrat but
I do have a strong sense of entitlement
and I do of course as you know have a
deep desire to control people and so I
think that makes me well qualified to be
the Democratic nominee and that's not to
say that I don't believe in freedom
first of all that's it that's a myth you
know that I don't believe in freedom I
just I certainly believe first and
foremost in in my own freedom and I also
believe that everybody else should be
free to do the stuff that I want them to
do so again my conception of freedom is
is is identical to the conception of
every Democrat it was on the stage last
night so just give me the job now as for
the debate most people seem to be saying
that Bernie Sanders was the big winner
of the contest last night so again I
have to kind of disagree with
conventional wisdom it seems to me that
Bernie was the the loser the biggest
loser even bigger than Bloomberg who
himself was certainly a loser as well
and I want to explain why first of all
but you know let's setting the stage as
it were everyone of course was landing
shots on Bloomberg last night was it was
like watching it was as if someone had
thrown a wounded rat into a piranha tank
and that's it was just a free-for-all a
feeding frenzy on Bloomberg and you
couldn't ask for a greater blessing
really if you're a Democratic candidate
to have this feeble old billionaire
degenerate on the stage with you so you
can practice your best anti billionaire
in souls it was they were all absolutely
thrilled to have him because because of
that opportunity provided to them and so
it was last night was sort of like
watching a training camp for socialist
demagogues with Bloomberg acting the
part of a tackling dummy
and the crazy thing is that the guy
seemed somehow completely blindsided by
the treatment he received now I guess
that's what happens when you you know
you've got sixty billion dollars and you
surround yourself with yes-men and
you're paying people to say nice things
about you on social media when you've
got that kind of money nobody around him
has the courage to stand up and say hey
listen mr. Bloomberg these people are
gonna skin you alive you are an old
white billionaire okay they're going to
skin you alive and then roll you around
insult that's what's gonna happen so be
prepared for that nobody said that to
Bloomberg so somehow he was unprepared
he walked in there and and managed to
come off like he wasn't expecting what
happened which is which is pretty
amazing probably the roughest moment of
the night was this this moment right
here watch this in a lawsuit in the
1990s according to Washington Post one
former female employee alleged that you
said quote I would do you in a second so
Democrats expect better from their
nominee let me let me say a couple
things and if I can have my full minute
in the quarter thank you I have no
tolerance for the kind of behavior that
the me to movement movement has exposed
and anybody that does anything wrong in
our company we investigate it and if
it's appropriate they're gone that day
but let me tell you what I do in my
company and my foundation and in city
government when I was there in my
foundation a person that runs it's a
woman 70% of the people there are women
in my company lots and lots of women
have big responsibilities they have paid
exactly the same as men and in my in
City Hall the person that's the top
person my deputy mayor was a woman and
40% of our commissioners were women I am
very proud of the fact that about two
weeks ago we were awarded we were voted
the most that the best place to work
second best place in America
if that doesn't say something about our
employees and how happy they are I don't
know what does yeah you see there he
didn't have a somehow he didn't have a
better answer prepared for that question
it took him off-guard and he also didn't
have an answer prepared for the other
this other line of attack from Elizabeth
Warren I'd like to talk about who were
running against a billionaire who calls
women fat broads and horse-faced
lesbians and no I'm not talking about
Donald Trump I'm talking about Mayor
Bloomberg are not going to win if we
have a nominee who has a history of
hiding his tax returns of harassing
women and of supporting racist policies
like redlining
and stop and frisk look I'll support
whoever the Democratic nominee is but
understand this Democrats take a huge
risk if we just substitute one arrogant
billionaire for another this country has
worked for the rich for a long time and
left everyone else in the dirt it is
time to have a president who will be on
the side of working families and be
willing to get out there and fight for
them that is why I am in this race and
that is how I will beat Donald Trump now
I think all of this was made so much
worse by the startling contrast between
Bloomberg's online persona the image
constructed by his marketing team and
the actual man himself anyone who was a
supporter of Bloomberg's if however many
of those people actually existed whoever
was supporting Bloomberg leading up to
the debate they had to feel like they'd
been catfished he's this online he's
he's this kind of irreverent and savvy
guy online or rather his social media
team is or tries to be oftentimes
failing but that's that's the the image
that he's trying to construct of himself
but then in person he shrinks and
shrivels in front of our very eyes and
he's already a pretty short guy so he
doesn't have a lot of room to spare by
the end of the debate he could barely
see over the podium Bloomberg
is basically the embodiments of every
loud mouthed loudmouth tough guy on
Twitter who gets all shy when you meet
them in person it was a disaster for him
now again what the image he wants to put
off is that he's savvy he's a tough guy
he's from New York he always talked
about how he's from New York you know no
nonsense he just wants to beat Donald
Trump cranky old bastard kind of thing
that's now and that would be if he could
actually pull that off if he had taken
that tack in the debate I think it would
work well for him but instead he became
even worse than shrinking away and
having zero charisma and zero
personality he was apologizing all over
the place
apologizing worst of all apologizing for
among other things his number one
accomplishment which was to
significantly lower the murder rate and
the crime rate in New York now that's a
that's a real thing that he did he
didn't do it by himself he doesn't get
all the credit for it but he did have
something to do with it that's a that's
a real accomplishment in in governance
and he apologized for that he backed
away from that he backed away from
everything which is the exact opposite
of what he needed to do the attitude he
needed to have was listen guys yeah you
know what um I'm rich okay I I'm
inappropriate I get all of that okay
maybe I'm maybe I'm not very palatable
to your to your sensibilities but look
at Donald Trump I'm the kind exactly the
kind of guy you need to go up against
Donald Donald Trump that's that's the
the selling his only selling point if he
has one but that's not what he went with
him steady just grovelled and apologized
and tried to get into a to a woke off a
woke contest with the Socialists on
stage and it didn't work out but as I
said I think that Bernie is the one who
lost the debate not Bloomberg and I'll
explain why in a second first a word
from paint your life you know we
we we sent in a couple months ago to
paint your life one of our favorite
pictures of the kids on on one of our
favorite in one of our favorite vacation
spots you know cherish picture of us of
ours and we've got it hanging now
proudly in the living room and it is
it's one of those things every time
somebody comes a new person comes to the
house they always notice the painting
and they start asking questions about it
so it's sort of a conversation piece
this is something I can't recommend
enough it's just it's a great thing to
do you can have an original painting of
yourself your children your family
special place a cherished pet at a price
you can afford
from paint your life calm this is a true
painting done by hand by a world-class
artist created from a favorite photos
this is not something they're doing son
if it's on a Photoshop trick okay it's
not like it's one of those pictures it
looks like it's a bit oh it's a real
painting by a real very talented artist
who does it for you you could make the
perfect gift for birthdays and
anniversaries or just something to do
for yourself and for you for your own
family you choose the artist whose work
you most admire and then you work with
them throughout the process is one thing
I was impressed by with paying your life
is how how receptive they are to
feedback and it's very sort of hands-on
process throughout the entire thing and
look there's no risk if you don't love
the final painting your money is
refunded it's as simple as that it's
great for decor it's a work of art with
paint your life you get your favorite
memories transformed into a work of art
that will be cherished forever right now
a limited time offer get 30% off your
painting that's right 30% off and free
shipping to get this special offer
text the word matte to 64,000 that's
matte to 64,000 text em ATT to 64,000
alright so as I said I think I think
Bernie Sanders actually the one who lost
the debate even though it was a disaster
for Bloomberg as well here's the moment
where Sanders lost it right here in the
country happens to be a millionaire with
three houses what'd I miss here
well you'll this time work in Washington
house watch the first problem live in
Burlington house - that's good and like
thousands of other for Martha's I do
have a summer camp forgive me for that
whatever is your home which tax which
tax haven New York New York City thank
you very much now first of all it's it's
pretty amazing that Sanders has done so
many of these debates and this is the
first time to my memory that anyone has
hit him for being a communist with a
million bucks in the bank in three
houses there's now he gets hit for that
all the time
among conservatives on Fox News and on
Twitter and everything but to his face
at a debate is the first time I can
think of that someone has brought that
up
and the guy who finally attacked him for
it has about twenty houses himself at a
minimum
so it took a billionaire to point out
that the Socialists who hates rich
people is a rich person himself but
here's the significance of this moment
remember everybody in the debate
everybody on stage landing punches on
Bloomberg left and right taking turns at
the pinata no blindfold right just a
just a metal bat and the pinata and
they're whacking it and there's tootsie
rolls and Jolly Ranchers flying all over
the place but then it's Bernie's turn at
the pinata and instead the pinata grabs
the bat out of his hand and whacks him
he got beat by the pinata Bernie was the
only one on the stage who got whacked by
Bloomberg he was the only one that
Bloomberg was able to low it to land a
blow on and if I'm a Bernie fan that
makes me pretty uncomfortable that my
candidate is so vulnerable and
susceptible that that Michael Bloomberg
was able to have a moment like that now
why did the attack work from Bloomberg
why was Sanders the one guy that even
Bloomberg with his total lack of
charisma and personality was able to
nail because Sanders is an
extraordinarily weak candidate whose
hypocrisy and inconsistency is hanging
there in the open just waiting to be
used against him he is a missing
he's a millionaire socialist that's
that's all you need to say then again
Bloomberg's the first guy to bring this
up in a debate you think Donald Trump
will be shy about bringing that up I
would predict that's gonna be one of the
only things that's just gonna be the
refrain over and over gonna keep going
back to that and consider how weak
Bernie's rejoinder was speaking of being
unprepared for a really obvious line of
attack now at least in Bernie's case he
was unprepared because no one's brought
it up before but he explains the the
three homes by calling his $600,000
vacation home a summer camp now Bernie
I've been camping okay that ain't
camping that's not any kind of camping
I've ever heard of a $600,000 lakefront
vacation home which is your third home
that's not camping so Bernie didn't do
himself any favors there and he didn't
do himself any favors here either
watch absolutely not I can't think of a
ways that would make it easier for
Donald Trump to get reelected and
listening to this conversation
we're not gonna throw out capitalism we
tried that other countries tried that
was called communism and it just didn't
work that was very telling that moment
there is of a small moment I don't know
it seems like people missed it but
Bloomberg mentions communism and a
negative light he besmirches the name of
communism and Bernie and Warren get very
upset they start raising whoa did you
hear that that was actually what that
was actually Warren's reaction whoa hey
hey come on come on leave communism out
of this communism never hurt anybody
except for a hundred million people that
are killed never hurt anyone except for
those last thing from the debate that I
want to mention is this moment from
Bernie Sanders if speaking to the needs
and the pain of a long-neglected working
class is polarizing I think you got the
wrong word what we are trying finally to
do is to give a voice to people who
after 45 years of work are not making a
nickel more than they did 45 years ago
we are giving a voice to people who will
say we are sick too tired a billionaires
like mr. Bloomberg seeing huge
expansions of their wealth while a half
a million people sleep out on the street
tonight and that's all we are saying
Pete is maybe it's the time for the
working class of this country to have a
little bit of power in Washington rather
than your billionaire campaign
contributors did you catch that Bernie
says there are people who've been
working for forty five years and don't
make a nickel more today than they did
45 years ago who what who who who
exactly I'm gonna need some specific
examples I'm gonna need you to provide
specific examples of people who've been
who have been I mean find me any adult
find me one adult in this country has
been working for forty five years for
half a century and is still making the
same amount today that he made that this
person made fifty years ago can you find
me an example of some
in that camp now even if I'm generous
and I allow for the possibility that
Bernie meant that they don't make a
nickel more than they did 45 years ago
image and when adjusted for inflation
that would still be BS because a person
who made five dollars an hour in 1975 45
years ago would make twenty four dollars
an hour today adjusted for inflation so
you're telling me there are people
who've worked jobs all that time for
half a century and all they have gotten
is inflation adjusted you know raises no
actual real raises in 45 years but this
is what this is what Democrats do I mean
rather than just sticking with reality
because in reality of course there are
people now I don't think there's anybody
who's been working for 45 years and
hasn't gotten a raise I mean imagine
that that be like you know you've got
someone who's who's 60 working since 15
hasn't gotten a raise
since the age of 15 I don't think
there's anybody like that but there are
plenty of people who are struggling
financially so you just say that that's
all you have to say there are people who
are struggling financially we would all
agree it's just like when we
talk about the minimum wage there are
people who are on the minimum wage and
are struggling okay yeah I agree with
that doesn't mean I agree that the
government needs to solve that problem
or can solve it without creating more
problems and creating those problems for
the very people it's trying to help but
you could say that there are people are
struggling on minimum wage that's true
the issue is when you start pretending
that for example there are people who
you know mothers who have been working
minimum wage for 10 years you know and
and and and haven't been able to get
over
he hasn't haven't been able to get over
even that hump of minimum wage like that
kind of thing it's it's just it's not
necessary to lie like that but that's
what that's what Bernie Sanders does and
that's another reason why he's so
vulnerable it would be so easy to beat
because he just says things says things
that have no basis in reality there's no
evidence for them and oftentimes he's
being inconsistent and hypocritical all
right before we move on I want to tell
you about honey you know honey is the
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart and I mean
everyone knows how great it feels to
safe and how and how bad it feels when
you spend more money than you need to on
something so why not save with honey
there's really no reason not to saving
with honey you know it's just it it it
feels as I said it feels great it feels
like you know hitting every green light
on your commute finishing up a podcast
episode right when you get to work it's
just it's a it's that perfect feeling
you know I've been using honey for
several weeks now and I can't imagine I
can't imagine going back to a time when
I'm shopping online and the thing is I
like most people these days I buy
probably really 80% or more of the stuff
that I buy in my life now I buy online
especially it's an antisocial person it
just makes it a lot easier or nothing I
don't the see people or interact with
them because who'd ever want that but I
use honey now and I'm just saving money
left and right did you know that honey
supports over 30,000 stores online
including Macy's Target
for a Best Buy and they're mad at adding
more every single day so if you get
honey now you know that it's only gonna
get better as time goes on and users
love honey and you know that because
there are over a hundred thousand five
star reviews on google chrome store you
can go and look at that for yourself
using honey feels pretty great just
think of it as a little daily victory
plus it's a free to use and it installs
in just a few seconds get honey for free
at join honeycomb slash Walsh that's
join honeycomb slash Walsh two
interesting items here that we will look
at together the first is another
question sent into slates advice column
the headline here is my wife wants to
have sex with her brother I'm not
opposed in principle I'm not opposed in
principle that's the question now I'm
not going to read the actual thing I
don't think you need the nitty gritty
details here suffice it to say that this
guy's in an open marriage with his wife
and meaning that they both have sexual
relations with other people and his wife
suggested happily one night that maybe
they should have a threesome with her
brother and the husband says that this
is an uncomfortable direction for them
to go but he has no real philosophical
objection to it in fact his main concern
is is that it'll make his relationship
with his brother-in-law awkward that's
the main thing is worried about now
credit to our intrepid advice columnist
in this case though because he does get
around to the right conclusion he says
at the end and this is sage advice for
everybody who says I don't think you
should do anything that makes you
uncomfortable particularly if it
involves having sex with your wife and
her brother I mean that's the kind of
advice you can live by frankly I I can
find nothing to criticize in that advice
of course the reason that slate takes
questions like this and puts them in
articles and in headlines and stuff is
that people notice them and react and
react in the same way which is revulsion
across the board across the board
revulsion but we have to ask why right
what exactly is the problem with an
arrangement like this if the husband
were to agree
would be something between consenting
adults and isn't that all that matters
so you we no longer have the language in
this culture to explain why something
like this is wrong though we know it is
I mean everybody does
we know that inherently and we don't
have the language because we otherwise
insist that the only ethical boundary
for sex the only rule that must be
followed is consent we've gotten used to
excusing anything on the basis of
consent but then so we've we've stripped
away all the rules of sex although all
the ethical guidelines all the
considerations that you're supposed to
take into account before having a sexual
relationship with somebody we we've
stripped all that away and we boiled it
down only to consent it's the only thing
that matters whereas in the past
I mean consent mattered but then there
were also other things too that you
should take into account the problem
though that we we've discovered is that
well it's actually not all about consent
consent is is is not the only thing
there are you know it is possible it
turns out to have a consensual sexual
relationship between adults that's still
wrong here's an example but we don't
have the language we don't have the
language for explaining what it is you
know when we when we see it or when we
hear about a sexual really we don't see
it when we hear about a sexual
relationship between consenting adults
that we still that we know is wrong you
know we know that it lacks something
that it should have or it has something
that it shouldn't but what is that thing
well I know what it is you you know what
it is hopefully but it's something with
implications that our culture finds
dangerous and and that's what leads to
this kind of confusion and that thing is
you know the the I think the word that
were people in our culture are
struggling to avoid or don't understand
is that it's disordered this is a
relationship that is dis
it is outside the proper order of things
so it disordered means why would it be
wrong for this husband and wife to have
sex with the wife's brother because
that's not what you do with your brother
this is not how the relationship is
supposed to work we all know that's the
answer we all agree or almost all of us
hopefully agree yeah we don't like the
answer because it introduces the concept
of proper order to human sexuality and
and that were afraid might be a knife
that cuts deeper than we want it to
we're okay with it with with with taking
that knife and carving out these really
perverse things out on the peripheral of
human experience in human sexuality
we're okay with getting rid of that
stuff
but what if it keeps cutting we worry
what then so most leftists will not say
that this relationship described in the
letter is it's a slate is disordered
that's not the word they're gonna use
that's not the language they're going to
use but then what word will they use
what can they say that's the point
there's nothing they know it's wrong but
they have no way of explaining why it's
wrong another example Utah is moving
towards decriminalizing polygamy
according to the Salt Lake Tribune well
what exactly is the argument against
that I could think of a few but none
that are consistent with the whatever
consenting adults do is okay ethic this
is the whole point of the the slippery
slope argument that people have made
when it comes to human sexuality and
marriage and opening up the deaf the
definition of marriage and this is why
by the way the slippery slope argument
is not a fallacy so when you make an
argument slippery slope argument so
that's a fallacy it's a slippery slope
know number one this thing that people
do online is sort of a side issue but
this thing people do online where they
try to rebut your argument just by
labeling of labeling it a certain
fallacy
they call it the whatever XYZ fallacy
and then they move on as if they've as
if that in itself suffices as a response
it's not there is nothing in itself
fallacious about making a slippery slope
argument the whole point of the slippery
slope argument is to say listen you are
justifying a certain thing certain
behavior a certain act whatever and
you're using certain arguments to
justify it now here's the problem what
if I can take that argument fully intact
and use it to justify something over
here that we both agree is wrong isn't
that an issue see what that would seem
to tell us is that either there's
something wrong with your argument or
there's something wrong with the thing
that you're trying to justify or maybe
that this thing over here is actually
okay too but it's going to be one of
those options and now we got to figure
out which one it is
as far as I could see it that's the
point of slippery slope argument and so
when people said things like well it's
only it all that matters is what
consenting adults do love is love so on
and so forth you know people who are
trying to protect the quote/unquote
traditional definition of marriage the
point we were making is okay but we that
argument can clearly be used if I could
take that argument fully intact and
clearly use it to justify this stuff
over here that even you think is wrong
that means that there's an issue here
and if you're not willing to argue that
these things over here are wrong then
there's only two possible conclusions
left there's something wrong with your
argument or there's something wrong with
the thing you're justifying that's what
we've discovered
turns out at a minimum love is love and
you know whatever consenting adults do
those are bad arguments at a minimum I
don't see any way around that all right
let's before we wrap up here let's check
in with LifeLock tax season can be a
pain in the butt but it's all worth it
when you open the mailbox and you see
the one envelope you've been waiting for
unless it turns out that someone else
already filed your return okay that's
gonna kind of ruin things for you during
tax season your personal info like your
name or social security number may be
emailed and shared more than usual
criminals can steal info from your
devices and sell it on the dark web or
use it to to commit identity theft
that's why you need life lock the number
one most recognized brand identity theft
protection
LifeLock monitors for use of your
personal info alerts you to possible
suspicious activity and if you become a
victim of identity theft a dedicated
identity restoration specialist will
work till 5th to fix it
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions are all from
all businesses but having life lock
means one less thing to stress about
during tax season and the thing is you
know no one can monitor all this stuff
but you yourself can monitor hardly any
of it and that's where life lock comes
in join now and save up to 25% off your
first year just go to life lock calm
slash Walsh that's life lock calm slash
walls for 25% off last thing here by my
dear friend AOC Alexandra occasional
Court says was on my favorite show the
view really great to have your two
favorite things together in that way and
she was surprisingly talking about the
evil rich men pretty shocking from her
to hear that kind of rhetoric
she's very rare sort of rhetoric from
AOC usually she'd be the last person on
earth to demonize someone for their
income so this is not the AOC that I
know anyway listen to what she had to
say our entire political system revolves
frankly around rich men and rich men are
not the center of my universe working
families are and
now now wait hang on a second here the
system revolves around rich men but they
aren't the center of her universe well
then what is this all about I could be
crazy but it sounds like a Oh see there
is saying that a rich white man taught
her about her value as a human being she
learned that she has a value as a person
from a rich white man yet rich white men
aren't the center of her universe
it sounds like they definitely are at
least one of them is and she also said
as usual that billionaires should not
exist I don't think that in a place
where 60% of Americans can't even you
know make more than $40,000 a year that
of the presence of a billionaire who
largely makes their money off of
businesses under paying their workers
like Walmart like Amazon like so on
should is better Bernie said the same
thing last night at the debate and I
have to tell you I will never quite get
used to hearing agents of the state say
that certain types of people shouldn't
exist
I will i I don't think it's I'll never
get used to it creeps me out to put it
to put it mildly but here's my question
for Bernie and AOC and everybody in
their camp first of all if billionaires
don't exist who's gonna pay for all the
socialist programs where's that money
coming from on one hand you say they
shouldn't exist and on the other hand
you say that they should pay to
reimburse everybody's student loans
along with a dozen other things you want
them to do and pay for so which is it
because they don't exist they can't pay
for that stuff and then who's gonna pay
for it
who would pay for it
then second what do you think happens to
those 60% of Americans that aoc
mentioned 60% who you know or whatever
she said making 40 or 50 grand or less a
year what happens to them when their
bosses the people who own the companies
they work for suffer massive losses in
income or disappearance I mean I don't
know what when you say billionaires
shouldn't exist do you want to just kill
these people I what do you want to do
you want to shoot them into the Sun
what's your plan exactly but let's take
the less violent approach or and assume
that you mean well we're gonna stop them
from being millionaires by just taking
almost all their money okay well what
happens then what happens to their
companies what happens to all their
employees have you thought about this
have you have you thought this through
at all no of course you haven't because
this is just childishness that's a lot
worse than childishness because it's
guessing it's coming from adults who
also are in government and have power so
I wish it was merely childishness but
it's that's that's about as as you know
in terms of the the intellectual
complexity of what we're dealing with
that's that's it it's this is this is
the mentality of a child saying they
have a billion dollars I don't have it
that's unfair they shouldn't have it
that's as far as it goes
and we'll leave it there but before we
do I want to give a shout out to all of
our daily wire members you know you guys
are the ones that keep us in business
and we love making content that matters
and while we're on the frontlines of the
culture war we know that we can't do it
without your support so you're also sort
of on the front lines with us if you're
still skeptical about joining the Daily
wire or readers past is a great start
and a great value readers pass will
enable news junkies to read our our
our articles ad-free including op-eds
from ben shapiro which are exclusive for
daily wired Members Only you get that
upgraded experience and in-depth
analysis from our editor-in-chief you
also get access to our mobile app which
has really become popular with all of
our members and you can read all of our
stories on mobile and you receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content it's perfect for when
you want to stay up to date on what's
going on and especially when you're on
the go and want to stay up to date so
this membership tier is already a
bargain at 3 bucks a month it's hard to
get much cheaper than that
but it does get cheaper than that
actually because now we're offering one
month for $0.99 that's mobile ad free
all access to the daily Wired news
exclusive op-eds from ben shapiro and
breaking news and updates on our mobile
app all for a low price of one dollar
one cent less than one dollar so give it
a shot it's worth it and we'll leave it
there Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20/20 Bloomberg smacked Bernie Warren
scalped Bloomberg and Joe Biden wrecked
himself we will examine the highlights
from the wildest 2020 Democratic debates
so far and specifically how Mike
Bloomberg fundamentally misunderstands
the presidency then AOC wants
billionaires to disappear and the
moralists of modernity at Slate Magazine
can't quite explain why it's wrong to
sleep with your brother all that and
more check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]